this is the 100th episode thank you all
for being a part of this location and
supporting toe along the way to make it
happen we've launched a contest for a
physics explainer video if you want to
explain some Physics phenomenon or
Consciousness Theory and do so in the
format of an engaging video then visit
the link in the description for more
information as there's just 10 days left
Brilliance has come on board to give
1000 USD to each of the five winners
entry closes sharply on October 31st 11
59 PM Toronto time
Stefan Alexander is a theoretical
physicist and a professor at Brown
University Salvatore Pius is an engineer
formerly at the U.S space force and
currently working for the U.S Navy
seldomly to those in Academia listen to
those who are from the outside and even
more rarely do they do so with such
compassion and mutual respect that both
Stefan and Sal show to one another this
is a first of its kind conversation on
toe that's meant to exemplify what
occurs behind closed doors but in front
of a public audience like yourself this
is the second time the Salvatore Pius
has ever conducted an interview the
first time also being on toe and the
link to that will be in the description
Sal is an elusive fellow Stefan
Alexander has also appeared on toe and
the link to that is in the description
there we talk about string theory and
another proposal for a Theory of
Everything called the autodidactic
universe during this conversation with
Sal and Stefano struck I still am struck
with covid so it was extremely difficult
for me to parse words together
cognitively however just like usual toe
episodes we still retain a level of high
technicality this episode premiered ad
free on theoriesofeverything.org before
you're seeing it here and that's one of
the benefits of being a toe member so if
you'd like to donate to tow to support
toe then visit theoriesofeverything.org
and you'll gain access to several
benefits now on to today's sponsor if
you're familiar with toe you're familiar
with brilliant but for those who don't
know Brilliance is a place where you go
to learn math science and engineering
through these bite-sized Interactive
Learning experiences for example and I
keep saying this I would like to do a
podcast on information Theory
particularly Chiara marleto which is
David Deutsch's student has a theory of
everything that she puts forward called
Constructor Theory which is heavily
contingent on information Theory so I
took their course on random variable
distributions and knowledge and
uncertainty in order to learn a bit more
about entropy now there's this formula
for entropy essentially hammered into
you as an undergraduate which seems to
have fallen from the sky however when
you take Brilliance course it was the
first time that I could see that it's an
extremely clear and intuitive formula
that is to say that it would be natural
to Define it in any other manner visit
brilliant.org toe that is toe to get 20
off the annual subscription and I
recommend that you don't stop before
four lessons I think you'll be greatly
surprised that the ease at which you can
now comprehend subjects you previously
had a difficult time grocking at some
point I'll also go through the courses
and give a recommendation in order thank
you and keep in mind the Salvatore Pious
and Stefan Alexander will both come on
separately for one-on-ones for part two
with Salvatore Pius and part two with
Stefan Alexander now enjoy this try log
this theolocution between Stefan
Alexander and Salvatore Pious what do
each of you see as the main issues with
either quantizing gravity or gravitising
the quantum air coins then calls it
geometrics in the quantum starting with
Stefan Professor Stefan Alexander please
um
well there are it depends on the
perspective you take
um
you know general relativity
um
Einstein theory of general relativity is
based on
um the principle of
background dependence or diffiomorphism
environments that coordinate labels are
fictitious I mean they are not physical
right you can always Define physics in a
completely different coordinate system
and the physics should be the same and
quantum mechanics you know in its
formulation at least
um in Quantum field Theory the structure
of quantum field theory for example if
you talk about you know unifying quantum
mechanics with special relativity
um you still are doing physics in some
given frame and you know making sort of
combining there's a tension now right
because how do you define quantum
mechanics in a background independent
way there have been attempts to do that
I'm happy to talk about those attempts
and you know they've seen some success
but um there's also
um
problems
um the main problem of course for me as
a just a physicist that pays a lot of
attention to observations is that
um it's difficult to explain
um
so sometimes some of these theories are
set to be um unphysical and I can get
back to that about what that means what
I'm physical means
um they're fraught with certain
conceptual and Technical problems these
background independent formulations of
quantum gravity and then you have things
like string theory which
is a successful perturbative way of
defining
of combining some aspects of general
relativity with quantum mechanics
um but again I I've worked on string
theory I've worked on string theory
mainly at the level of string
phenomenology or string cosmology and
you know it provides a good toolbox but
also
String Theory itself has its own issues
and unresolved problems and that's why
it's still an active field of research
so that's my little summary about um why
quantum gravity is so hard to so we we
currently don't have a consensus in
terms of the um you know physicists we
don't have a consensus about a theory of
quantum gravity so if we don't have a
consensus then we don't really have a
theory of quantum Revenue
actually uh Professor Alexander I agree
with every every syllable you've added
uh it makes a lot of sense yes
think of it possibly possibly just to
add a little
maybe from ignorance or lack of
knowledge uh uh deep within physical
Theory but what if it's not just about
quantizing the gravitational field or
geometrizing the quantum as Dr Weinstein
Eric Weinstein says what if it's about
something else as well what if there is
a Super Force a force of unification
that somehow combines all four forces
given that the force of gravity is
acceptable as a force and not just a
space-time curvature and so forth
and this Super Force could be
for example Isaac Newton let's go back
to
way before all right circus 1693 A.D
thank goodness for that uh 1693 he
writes a letter to one of his buddies
Richard but I think Sir Richard Bentley
he says What If gravity is the result of
an agent
big a capital a that acts
constantly
throughout the Universe in accordance to
given laws of nature
and my question is what if this agent
capillary is the Super Force now
Professor abbay ashtaka which by by the
way I think Quantum balance should be
called ashtaka bounds in the in the lqg
in Loop quantum gravity
um
and I think it he's got something and we
have to discuss this this whole idea of
the ashtaker bonds Quantum bonds uh
because there may be some sort of Super
Force super density resulting in a super
bang I know I know
you see what happens when you agree to a
conversation with uh so let me interject
if you don't mind I want to frame this
conversation I know that I've said this
to both of you Stefan Alexander is a
professor of theoretical physics at
Brown University and holds many
accolades and I'll list those in the
actual intro itself and Salvatore Pius
is an engineer working at the Navy us
space four slash I know that you can't
say exactly what your position is but
the point is that rarely to those in the
academic circles listen to those who are
outside of it especially when those who
are on the outside feel like they have
some Grand idea because you generally
get pitch them left right and Center
when you're an academic and so it's
difficult to separate the wheat from the
chef with Stefan what I like about you
is that you
take your cues from physics from Jazz
which is that if someone throws you an
idea you play with it and you throw it
back to the person you mentioned that
this is how you work with your graduate
students so this is supposed to be or
this is this whole conversation is an
example of what would ordinarily happen
behind closed doors being brought to the
public and so hopefully it's something
that researchers
can aspire to so that's what frames this
conversation this exactly so this
respect that seldom shown in
compassionate between let's say Academia
and those who are outside when they have
large ideas Grand ideas Grand
unification
right so on that note on that note so
let me um ask
um let me respond to Sal
uh sure that's great so first of all Sal
uh please call me Stefan uh thank you
sir appreciate it yeah and um
so so I'm gonna push back a little bit
I'm gonna say well you you push I'm
gonna push back and agree with you the
first thing I'm going to agree with is
that your idea of let's say the Super
Force meaning that UNIF that
quantization of gravity
can only happen with a unification
scheme where basically there's some
Force let's call it your Super Force or
some force or
something that underlies all
the force of gravity right and the
forces that quantum mechanics actually
you know um unifies itself so Quantum
field theory was an example of a way of
unifying the three interactions the
three um you know the weak interaction
the strong interaction and the
electromagnetic interaction at least I
mean Quantum field theory is a language
at least okay um you know Quantum fuel
Theory engage invariance right is the
language right or the technology the
conceptual mathematical technology that
underlies those three forces right and
the Super Force you know this
unification of gravity with these other
three forces
this was actually the program of
strengthening right
string theory and it's it's parent you
know when people some people call I
think I find this it's parent Theory
actually very interesting Matrix Theory
right the idea that you know what even
underline what underlines the
overarching framework that
um that string theory
comes from is a matrix
um quantum mechanics so now I think what
is interesting about what you're saying
is that
there's one thing to say that forces
including gravity are Unified
but your perspective what I'm hearing
your perspective is that you're calling
that unification a Super Force and
therefore I'm gonna ask you what is that
Force
okay
thank you sir thank you very much for
this uh wow
wow okay first of all I hope it's not
contestational biology no oh wow
we'd have to involve uh uh Dr Wolfram uh
some other some other notables in it
maybe um by the way down the road uh if
you could discuss your idea of the
Rhythm Universe I I'd really like to
hear more and I have a question for my
10 year old daughter for you okay great
great so just remind me okay but just to
go back to the Super Force thank you
very much for for engaging with me and
it means a lot because you not only do
do you have the right pedigree but do
you you are extremely well known and
extremely well liked in the community so
God bless you for this sir thank you
nice to meet you thank you thank you
thank you very much oh come on anybody
that Professor Leon Cooper would would
think highly of everybody else should
think of very anyway I mean he was the
he is the god of superconductivity I
mean the the other two I think have
passed away a bardine and Shriver but
anyway may they rest in peace by the way
they're the the BCS theorism remarkable
anyway so the Super Force is uh C to the
fourth so it's like the speed of light
to the fourth power divided by Big G
now Professor ashtaker is correct in
saying wait uh it cannot be fundamental
because it doesn't have the H bar in it
but if you think of it it's really the
plank force and what how does the plank
Force come about it's the Planck energy
which is the m the the plan mass times c
squared
divided by the plank uh length which is
what uh GH bar divided by C cubed the
whole thing square root of
but because it's um yeah but anyway so
if you do that the H bar drops out now
what's really cool about this the Super
Force being the blank Force talks
directly to general relativity because
if you look at Einstein's field
equations which you very well know I
mean I could do the whole thing with the
reminding curvature times the space-time
metric but let's call everything on the
left hand side uh g g sub Nunu asterisks
because it's got the cosmological
constant termination
right exactly sure and and and equals
what if it's eight pi times Big G
divided by C to the fourth you see when
you do the dimensional analysis oh and
and that scalar that the eight pi times
Big G divided by C to the fourth is
multiplied by the uh stress energy
momentum tensor your uh T sub mu Nu
right but when you do the dimension the
scaling analysis and that you realize
that that one divided by L Square goes
as
um L divided by E times e divided by L
cubed which is the energy density the T
sub nu nu so that that that scalar
constant that acts in the Einstein field
equations is representative of a force
and it's really representative of the
plan force and you got to ask yourself
what's this blank for Super Force call
it what you want quality Alexander Force
who knows maybe one day you'll be able
to use it and improve with experimental
data that this thing does exist
I still do believe it exists at blank
sales but anyway let me not not diverge
I'm I'm just so enthusiastic that
finally someone of your of your great
aptitude is engaging that that you know
I'm I'm a little bit so I apologize if I
seem too enthusiastic but okay uh so
what I'm trying to say is that what is
the plan Force doing
in the Einstein field equations if it
wasn't a bridge between the the the
world of the very small quantum
mechanics and the world of the very
large general relativity okay
um
so I mean I think you know dimensional
analysis is always a great um
a great path path to take when we're
trying to understand new things about
that the theory may not be same
um right so scaling analysis is scale
analysis and um
in dimensional analysis is um I think a
great way to proceed how um one one
question I have of course is that no
matter what you do with the Einstein
field equation right you can always I
mean at the end of the day
right and a good exercise just to walk
everyone through this on the left hand
side the Einstein equation we have the
notion of curvature or you know let's
say geometry
um is related or equated with right
um energy momentum right matter and you
know
um and energy so
you know typically I mean when we at
least bread and butter relativists and
cosmologists that I am
we tend to use fields of fluids to
discuss you know to discuss that
framework so we have on the left hand
side we have a we have the equivalent of
a field in this case the Dynamics of the
gravitational field
um seen through the lens of curvature
and on the right hand side we have
of like basically fluids or Fields uh
matter Fields right so
um and then we of course we have matter
or fields or fluids whatever right space
time and basically there is a the system
is non-linear and there's what we call a
back reaction wow you know the mitochon
curve the geometry and the geometry the
curve geometry makes them at a move and
then that in that in turn like you know
back reacts right so you have because
system is non-linear
now I can choose to put vacuum energy or
the cosmological constant on the right
hand side right and it it it appears to
behave like a form of matter or I could
put it on the left hand side right and
that actually ends up becoming something
that looks like the radius of curve the
radius of the set of space right so
basically if I have a positive
cosmological constant I haven't you know
I have a space
now so
if I get rid of all of my if I work in
complete vacuum and I can choose that I
can choose to work a complete vacuum
with a cosmological term
right is it not the case that that this
what you call in the Super Force is
something that couples to the to this
vacuum energy
I see what you're saying I mean there's
nothing unless you're on unless you're
adding something else to the Einstein
field equation that's what you have to
work with now you can you could do that
you could modify Einstein's theory there
are ways to do this right so are you
asking to are you are you modifying
um General activity or are you
re-packaged in no way to say that that
you know some blocking scale vacuum
energy is what you're calling the
Superfast that's my question
basically the right hand side drops to
zero where's your Super Force and what
you're left with is a vacuum solution
but what I'm saying is don't do that
because it's like choosing natural units
if you choose natural units you know the
whole idea of c equal H bar equal Big G
equal one
you get rid of the Super Force to begin
with but you still left with the beauty
of Einstein's field equations namely
space-time curvature geometry is mass
energy which is exactly what it couples
do so the physics is still there but
you've given you've you've taken away
some of the physics that's inherent to
the strength to the what's what I'm
looking for to the power of the Einstein
equations and the beauty of the Einstein
equations is that they can be
reformulated if you leave the C to the
fourth divided by Big G in there if you
leave the Super Force term in there
it it takes a whole different Nuance
because it basically says on a Quantum
scale it's possible that if you think of
the left hand side as a spatial temporal
geometrical structure
then what it says it's the super force
acting on the spatial temporal
geometrical structure that gives rise to
matter to energy density
that's a whole different look a whole
different understanding of what GR
has been telling us it's it's a new
perspective on Old physics
not new physics I I cannot stand when
people use the idea of new physics what
if it's just a new perspective on all
physics nothing wrong with all physics
offices like good wine you know you
leave it it matures it tastes even
better
yeah but if I'm if I'm you know I if I
work in natural units I mean I can
always free feel free to choose what
units I want and I should you know I
should see the same physics right agreed
which which that's why uh how should I
say uh uh the the only problem that I
see with that is that once you choose to
work with natural units not only do you
discard the physics of the Super Force
it's no longer there but you actually
discard dimensional
scaling analysis it's no longer
dimensionally correct
because then it says 1 divided by L
Square goes goes as e divided by L cubed
where's the equivalence in that
do you see what I mean when you use
natural units and get rid of that scalar
all of a sudden it doesn't make
dimensional sense anymore and I I
understand from a Dimensions point of
view maybe Dimension shouldn't matter
anyway but
when you translate those Dimensions 1
divided by L Square as being your
space-time curvature so that's your left
hand side and goes as e divided by L
cubed whoa it's basically saying yeah
space-time geometry is like
in a you know an energy density yeah I
understand
but from a dimensional perspective it's
no longer there it is no longer there
how can one divided by A square B is e
divided by L cubed when e is really your
m c square there's something not right
when you use natural units and drop out
the superfox I understand what you mean
overall physically that well in that
case C is just m
right in those not in those units he is
just m
right hi that's not C Square fine but
even then one divided by L squared goes
to M divided by L cubed even from uh you
see what I'm saying even from I mean how
Okay say you you keep the M it's still
divided by a are you saying that a mass
divided by a volume goes as one divided
by a square are you saying that an uh uh
how should I say a mass
density what's right because that's what
m divided by lq a mass density goes as
really one divided by a surface area
you see what I'm saying it no longer
makes physical sense at that point once
you use the natural units and get rid of
the superfoster and the C4 divided by
Big G that's all I'm saying
yeah well
I'll have to you know for me I'll have
to see I mean
I have to see you know I'm the would you
look at some paper I come up with sure
I think that that's fair that is that
means a lot that means a lot and I would
really love to stay in touch with not
only because when you we're New York
City Boys we basically you know I went
to Brooklyn Technical High School and
you knew uh Dekalb Avenue J Street like
the back of your hand I remember you
spoke of Dr Kaplan I think I want I once
met him because he was a good friend of
uh Dr Arthur Dawson from Brooklyn Tech
and also a Mr Lawrence Zimmerman those
are Ahmad you know they're the ones that
brought me up yeah yeah well you know
what what we call a homeboy yeah
but I think you and I had to have a lot
of in in our origins in our background
the way we grew up and you know New York
City guys a lot of people thought yeah
at least a lot of people throw it out at
Mount do nothing yeah you know what I
mean and I mean look at you what what
you've achieved so hey you know
I did I did some I did something wrong
all right so let's let's take this
further down so just
you know what is um let's see so you
talked about um you know I've actually
abai is a a great mentor of mine and he
was very
um very kind to me so when I was when
nobody else wanted to hire me he was the
one that was behind
um my first faculty job at Penn State
and my office was next to his for a
number of years and I learned quite a
bit from the from about ashtakar he is a
genius right and um so and I took I took
some time to learn some not all because
it's very tough technical stuff new
quantum gravity
um I even tried to you know develop some
ideas around the ashtaker hashtag
variables
um so it's something that I'm always
um you know an admirer of you know um I
I do have some problems with the loop
quantum gravity program and you know
um I can see the lease at least small to
be a good friend
um
um
I think that I uh you know the minute
when you were talking about this this
bounce uh that happens in say Luke
Quantum cosmology yes sir um there is a
sense in which like there is um you know
I once heard um
um
given analogy that somehow when we think
about since it is a quantum theory and
geometry is quantized then the idea was
that the perhaps a Quantum reason behind
the bounce is that as space-time you
know if you think about the sort of the
structure of space-time being cellular
or discrete
um it is that you get to some you get to
some region and there is some repulsive
question courses so is that the thing
you're you're kind of pointing yes
that's a I'm I'm seeing exactly that the
Super Force resides at the ashtaker
bounds it is the Super Force that
actually possibly uh at Super density
condition and what super density really
density at playing scale so it's your
you know uh speed of light to the fifth
power the whole thing divided by the
denominators like uh a big G Square H
bar your H bar is your reduced by cancer
and that's how H bar comes in because
Professor ashtaker when he heard of the
my formula for the Super Force use like
but the the it's not Quantum in nature
can be fundamental but it talks to a
super density
and and the beauty of it is because it
doesn't have the H bar that it couples
with the Einstein equations as as you
and I have been conversing you and I can
discuss this more because I see you know
I see your point very well as well so so
but what I'm saying is what if the Super
Force is what makes the ashtaka balance
happen when you say that the Super Force
resides at the Astra car bounce do you
mean to say that the Super Force comes
into play at the level when the Ashton
car bounce becomes relevant or the Super
Force is the ash the car bounce no no no
no no the ashtaker bounce is this
Quantum bounce that uh that Professor
Alexander was speaking of that basically
can be used instead of uh inflation
Theory and so forth to but anyway look
what I'm trying to say uh let me let let
me Focus uh on the thoughts because this
is important let me give the analogy of
a supernova explosion the way way it
does the way for example anything about
a type 1A uh Supernova this would apply
to the mechanism is basically that of a
core collapse that leads to something
called core bounds and it happens at
very high densities on the order of like
2.4 times 10 to the 14 grams per
centimeter Cube
at those extremely high densities this
core bounds occurs because of the what
the strong nuclear force comes into
being and this thing is what leads to
the um uh extremely violent expulsion of
the outer core of the star so I'm saying
I'm taking something that's extremely
small and analogizing it with something
that happens in a supernova mechanism
but it's almost the same idea the core
bounce really happens in this case
because of the extremely high density
which brings in the strong nuclear force
and I'm saying at the quantum balance
it's not the strong nuclear force it's
the Super Force that acts
and what's really interesting and I hope
to prove this to Professor Alexander one
day I really hope you sir I really hope
you take the time to to read the paper
that I have in mind I wish I had the
pedigree of a physicist so maybe you're
able to I mean and I'll try in that
paper to to make much stronger
mathematical arguments as to what I'm
saying but from a physical mechanism
point of view just think of the analogy
of a core bounce that happens upon the
core collapse of a supernova explosion
that's exactly what I'm talking about
but on a Quantum level you see what I'm
saying so so basically some some
repulsive force that yeah
prohibits further contraction so that
that also means that black that black
holes um no space-time singularities
exist yes sir okay no yeah so I mean
again you know what I do what I am
sympathetic to here is that and I'm I'm
for me physics is also about ideas right
now the way ideas are mathematically
implemented and what theoretical
framework is also obviously very
important because the name of the game
is to sort of push the structure so
identify where the theory breaks down
replace it with a good idea and then
hopefully that idea leads to a new
structure
um that under the right approximations
gives you back actually the old Theory
right so in this case yes we have in the
Einstein equations we have we have
situations included in the quantum
cosmology
um
we do have a framework to talk about
such repulsive
um forces that do prohibit bounces in
general right however they are fraught
with you always run into some issue with
these types of
um forces and I'm happy if um Kurt
allows me to share the screen to kind of
maybe
show a diagram of what that could look
like what those where those problems
will lie so maybe something that Sal
cell could think about okay you should
have sharing capabilities right so
on the
y-axis so what we have here
is um
what do we have on the y-axis yeah so
what we have on the um
what we have on the
x-axis is time and what we have in a
y-axis is
you know right now this I'm going to put
this I'm going to put the Einstein field
equations in the context of an expanding
Universe okay yep um so so what we have
is the expansion parameter which is a
the scale factor so if you know we have
a little cartoon picture of of our
universe is that this scale factor a
right which determines scales in my
theories like spatial scales right as a
function of time
um
right this thing the scale factor expand
it basically grows in time and this is
how this is to say that the universe or
scales are expanding
um and the universe is expanded okay so
so we have a as a function of time
and the prediction of our standard
cosmology is that if you if you fill our
universe the universe is filled with
radiation and matter right that's going
to make you know that's going to make
the universe expand and then the
radiation and matter will dilute right
it's it's it's
um because of the expansion
um the
the um the density right like the energy
density and the matter density will
basically
um its amplitude will decrease as the
universe expands and that makes some
good into intuitive um um then the
volume is expanding therefore the
density
um will actually decrease
um
so
um the density being the amount of
energy or amount of divided by the
volume so the volume is expanded it's
growing then that that quantity is
decreasing
um provided that you have um
conservation of matter and energy is the
rate of expansion aged like a a DOT
divided by a are we talking about
expansion that's that's right so okay
thank you very much so the a DOT over a
is exactly as you said is the Hubble
parameter
and what the beautiful thing about the
Freeman equation about is that the
Einstein field equation
right as you said g mu Nu
right uh um is equal and I'm now going
to use my natural units all right I'm
gonna I just think I'm calling this
Kappa right that's that that includes my
plan you know
um G new and a pi a pi Cube times T mu
right and that's my energy momentum
now
this
these 10 differential equations
right collapse into two one I'll just
write the one that matters here because
I want to talk about the bounce now this
becomes on the left hand side
the only degree of freedom in the
gravitational field is the scale factor
because of the homogeneity and isotopy
and so we got an equation I see that
you've seen before which said that the
Hubble parameter Square
which is like a DOT over a square so a
is like a velocity right so the velocity
of the of the of the expansion rate
which is related to H square right I'm
just going to put this proportional
because I I um I'm using my mouse to
draw this equation
to the energy density contained in the
universe so this is the total energy
density of matter and radiation
everything is contained here now if I
plot now the solution of the of a
all right what we see is basically the
following
um
as a function of time as we go let's say
we start at T is equal to zero right
we got that this thing's the scale
factor grows
um as you know some power
um a power of time right so to the
one-third t to the two thirds but it
basically it's not medium right yeah it
grows exactly right
all right and what you find is that
actually at T is equal to zero when you
go to T is equal to a goes to zero right
oh it goes to zero well look at that and
a goes to zero notice that when it goes
to zero H goes to Infinity yeah and H is
basically what we call you know is
related to the curvature it's a Dynamics
you know it's related to G
right so effectively you know the
curvature right
um this Einstein tensor you know since
this is the only degree of Freedom so
what happens is that this is what we
call a singularity right right right
right right right so that's the
singularity and
um it's basically one a when this scale
factor goes to zero the curvature blows
up the curvature invariance actually
um or we sometimes call a crutchman
scalar
um that actually that's an environment
quantity that goes Infinity
all right so now that that's just a
little kind of quick you know except so
we're both on the same page yes sir so
one way you can get around this though
and people have played with this idea
including myself
is that you have your total matter and
all the stuff right and then you again
this is
imagine you have a theory then that
that's as close to the singularity
right you know some extra
some extra
um
in fact I'm just going to put s
subscript s for something right
okay
um and the idea is that you know as t
goes to some critical time close to the
Big Bang but not quite a t is equal to
zero T critical
this kind of this the um the total
matter and and this conspires to cancel
out cancel each other out because this
minus sign right can cancel this you
know your the um the ordinary matter and
energy in our universe and what happens
is that H goes to zero and not infinity
and so what does that picture look like
that picture looks like this
on the this is the expansion side this
is a positive branch and my negative
time
and what you find is um what something
like that would look like is the
universe contracts
avoids this is H
you know
um goes through zero and expands back
out and we call this a bounce right yeah
so it doesn't it avoids it bounces
um it bounces in a sense that it doesn't
it doesn't it goes to some a it doesn't
a never gets is never allowed because of
that to go to zero it goes to some
critical a that's really tiny as you
like very very time not zero yeah in
fact in Luke Quantum cosmology that is
the Planck scale all right and in Loop
Quantum cosmology you
this this thing does emerge from Luke
Quantum cosmology
and that's one of the I think one of the
the um what you call one of those things
the good one of the nice features of
that of that program now there are other
problems with lukewarm cosmology
um that um that at this point they keep
on bringing this lack of fermionic
matter that it doesn't lead to I mean
what's the story what's the story with
the lack of formatic matter yeah that's
interesting you know the the whole idea
is that uh uh and this is something that
was brought up uh several times by also
Michio Kaku keeps on saying for example
that lqg leads to uh lack of fermions it
basically doesn't show for me
I don't see it either I mean I mean for
God's sake this comes from the guy with
a god equation you know you thought
anyway I'm not gonna go there
but but anyway I I don't see his point I
mean I think uh uh Dr Weinstein has has
uh has some ideas uh uh with this
geometric Unity with you know with with
the with making uh lqg yield you know
because he he talks about these uh
family like um family of three um
formionic families something of that
nature
yeah yeah yeah so I guess well maybe
what what Mitchell Kaku is probably
talking about is how to how to formulate
fermions
um because in Luke chronography you're
using these gravitational Wilson loops
and
sure typically and um you know in and
you know that idea actually in new
chronic gravity came directly from Ken
Wilson uh the Nova board who invented a
lot of stage Theory right and so the
idea is that since Luke quantum gravity
by using the ashotech variables um
by using the sticker variables you can
write reformulate general relativity to
resemble a gauge Theory then you can use
um Wilson Loops which was like age
theoretic it's a quite a beautiful idea
gorgeous you can carry over the Wilson
Loop idea but the problem here is that
you know when you do Wilson Loop ideas
um there are the the so-called fermion
doubling problems these issues that I'm
not too well versed on I'm aware of them
and and I am aware that there are ways
around that and I do know that this is
an open-ended question a research
question in Loop quantum gravity to be
able to to be able to um and that's why
research exists right so that people
could correctly and that's why
categorical statements right they
shouldn't make categorical statements
like lqg makes no sense because it
doesn't yield for a manic man that's you
see what I'm saying it's it's there's no
we should try to see how to enhance one
one another's theories rather than put
each other down I agree with that
yeah when we can try we can try to learn
from each other um
you know as you know in fact Leon Cooper
once told me when um I was a graduate
student of his
um we would
you would always have somebody in the
room who was always trying to
um
to to
um
overstate or put somebody else down
um or or you know speak over somebody in
the group
and
and usually that would have that would
happen when um we might be stuck on
something let's say right and then one
and Leon would say Albert Einstein told
me
that if we knew what we were talking
about we wouldn't call it research
right right and I'm just like well okay
there it goes you know from the Grand
Master himself right okay right
oh Kurt would you like to say something
sir
yeah Stefan when you show the row sub s
and you said at the time you didn't know
what it was you just gave it a label s
what is it do you recall what that
specific variable is called and also is
that just positive or is that somehow
derived from Luke well if you that's
right so that's good yeah thanks so um
so what I just gave you was a was a
general framework for how you might want
to avoid
um you know approaching a curvature
Singularity which is exactly what a
black hole will have and what
um the Freeman
um Walker the Friedman equations of
general relativity to have for an
expanding universe
and the way that that can get
implemented is now Theory dependent so
for example in
um I've worked on some of these ideas
and what I
um me and my collaboration so first of
all let's back up if you look on the
right hand side you have row s and
there's a minus sign and whenever you
have a negative energy State that's like
that's basically like having a negative
energy state right and
if you allow a negative energy state to
propagate then people there's a big
worry because you could not um those
degrees of things are usually called
ghosts
right when you have negative energy at
states that are propagated so a ghost
usually is something that will have if
you have a negative kinetic energy so
um you know
whenever so Paul The Rock actually you
know um you know you know and and
stuckleberg and Feynman actually right
they saw these negative energy states in
the Klein Gordon equation of quantum
field Theory and the way around that was
to reinterpret having an eventually
State as an anti-particle moving
backwards in time right okay so you
enter you you said Okay I accept that
those things are but it's real what what
that real what that negative energy
stable is a positive energy state right
that's an anti-particle moving backwards
in time right so
um that's one way out of it you
reinterpret it another way out of it is
if you you know you identify you can
identify if if it's a fermion right it
does you you do occupy these negative
energy states like the rock C right and
then the Exclusion Principle you know
will prevent you know the sea from
collapsing yes yes yes okay so
um but you do have to confront with your
theory why you would have this negative
Advantage you say that's bounded from
below and my the ideas that I work on
with my you know my students and
colleagues um was that what contributes
our negative energy state is a bound
state of fermions
right and so bound States
and if it's fermionic right
could could be in that you know so in
quantum mechanics you know bound states
are negative energy states so you know
the right right the the the
um the board you know the energy
um the ground the ground state energy of
um of um of hydrogen is minus 13.6
electron volts there's a minus sign
there right so the negative energy
states do exist in quantum mechanics and
those states are the bound States so
bound states are negative energy states
right so that's kind of the game we
played and so we're able to get a Bounce
by having fermionic bound States
actually like a Koopa pair
um but then you run into other problems
if you do that because then you have to
look you know if you do that you have
you can study fluctuations and in
cosmology we're not only interested in
just the homogeneous you know um average
expansion rate but we need to consider
fluctuations to talk about structure and
so you can ask if you turn on
fluctuations do these negative energy
states cause runaway Solutions and
that's an open-ended problem
now in the Ashoka formulation as
occurred as
this negative thing emerges naturally
right and so and so for me that's quite
interesting because
you know your hamiltonian in Lucan
cosmology is bounded it's I mean they
actually call Lewandowski measure right
it's a rigorously defined in a product
and so you you know you do have a
well-defined hamiltonian
and so the the fact that you know when
you work in the in the frw type of
background from the quantum cosmology
you get this minus sign
um it does seem to suggest that there is
some kind of like Quantum pressure or
some kind of Exclusion Principle happen
at the level of the space time right to
kind of prevent like a super density
okay like a super density right so I
think it's I think what you're saying is
quite interesting
but it'll be interesting to to awaken
that and a framework like like Lucan
gravity if you think of it as a super
density term it's got the H bar in there
it's in the the denominator and then
Professor ashtakar's question you know
this may not be fundamental maybe it
talks to a super density maybe uh what I
call a Super Force really we use
terminology here you know what I'm
saying no no no and I I get yeah Super
Force sounds cooler yeah I mean truly
you know like space four super fours
right yeah yeah right right right so I
have a question for you before I forget
my my my 10 year old by the way things
oh my God things things is the coolest
uh um
name of a book ever the Jazz of physics
I mean oh yeah she uh she promised me
that she was gonna start
you know reading it you know I mean this
is not for ten-year-old but uh this is a
kid I I tell you this kid I think she
gets all her neurons from her mother I
can't take credit actually Stephen
Pinker gave me the title for my book
really physics
you're also a musician so it yeah I mean
I'm pretty sure you still
as far as I'm concerned it's your book
it's your title there you go that is
true I do I do play the saxophone yeah I
gotta hear that oh man I gotta hear this
we gotta hear this I have it right here
hey hey Kurt beautiful horn huh we
should close this up with him oh my god
with Professor Alexander playing that'd
be super cool okay okay
here comes the question this is really
before I forget it because she was like
Daddy you gotta ask uh
um uh she called you by the way these
kids man they you know the the idea of
respect she calls you Stefan because
because it's a so so please forgive her
because she does you know who knows
maybe one day she'll be a student so you
exactly you better call your professor
Alexander then okay
by the way if she um Brown University
would be unbelievable as an alma mater
but anyway oh okay yeah mine's uh Case
Western Reserve University the same as
Professor Keating so yeah that's my
buddy yeah yeah that's right uh okay now
now um okay she's basically saying ask
him
in his opinion what is the cause of
gravity and you'll see why she's asking
this
what is the
cause of gravity
oh I know
this kid asked that I told you I I wish
that's a that's a deep question
that's a deep question I mean because
you know obviously you have to give in
from the you know what what is the cause
of gravity right
um you know we'll say well
matter and energy is a cause of gravity
but then it becomes a chicken and egg so
what's the cause of matter and energy
then becomes a Wheeler thing you know it
from bit you know but anyway yeah yes we
know with someone else but answer what
answer did you give her let me let me
she has this this this unusual way of
thinking she I I talked before you know
the of the Casmir Force you know the
whole thing you know it goes as one
divided by the the D4 you know so the
academy Force becomes incredibly
important and you know to vacuum energy
densities uh uh terms you know because
of the when those non-conductive metal
plates whatever are brought together
very very small distances from one
another
because of the one divided by D to the
fourth term in the denominator
this thing just skyrockets the force
becomes incredibly high oh is this oh
okay I had this thing just pop on my
thing but anyway so so she thinks Daddy
what if because everything's connected
what if it's some sort of chasmir force
on a macroscopic scale this is a
technical Casimir forces what yeah what
what if what if gravity is due to
customer forces on a macroscopic scale
um I'm like I I could ask Professor
Alexander that if that even makes sense
but anyway yeah that's what but anyway
yeah I just bring it up yes yeah she's
quite a kid I tell you she gets all her
neurons from her mother but anyway
oh Stefan do you want to respond to that
and then I have a question
well I'm still trying to wrap my head
around
um the statement
um
um
you'd think that you'd think that that
that that that thing will that Force
you know we'd have to ask that question
in the context of a cosmological
space-time right because you know
because then you have a scale factor so
wouldn't wouldn't it get red shifted by
the scale factor I mean you have to like
um would definitely I I mean
you know a 10 year old but still the the
whole idea to her came because I showed
a video one time of of two ships in the
port
it was close to the port so close to the
coastline and if you bring the ships
together these things have a tendency to
attract one another they're they're
brought together
so so now like well with naval ships you
gotta be very careful not to bring them
too much in proximity of what of one
another or you'll have tremendous issues
so you see what I'm saying we were
talking about Casimir forces and how
these things are attractive and somehow
it became in her idea like in her idea
just like the two uh plates the two
non-conductive metal plates in in in in
that bring about the Casmir Force are
brought together because of precious
acting that are basically pushing the
the plates together she thought what if
this was a macroscopic Quantum phenomena
you know that somehow it translated
because everything is connected and if
you think from the point of view what if
everything was connected because of the
existence of the Super Force because it
does exist at every point in space and
time but you know I'm saying Super Force
because I like to think in terms of
forces rather maybe it's a super density
maybe the whole idea is analogous to the
whole idea of a core bounce in a
supernova
you know it comes about because of the
strong nuclear force the whole idea in
the ashtaker bounce it comes about
because of the existence of this super
density
which would be on the you know on the
order of a plank density
actually uh professor ashtaker says on
the order of 10 to the minus three times
the Planck density
yeah it's hard to see how these um
microscopic things um Quantum things you
know I mean unless you have some kind of
face coherence right like a macroscopic
Quantum state
um you know I mean
superconductivity is is a Microsoft
Quantum phenomena truly it certainly is
it definitely is yeah that's how they
were able to derive it from the London
forces the the London equations the
whole idea of the law they call it
London penetration depth right it's it's
the whole idea of the the Meisner effect
see I'm constantly trying to get
Edwinton to come onto theories of
everything and he always responds to me
but he says no however there's one way
that he can come on why because I think
they say no he's just so busy one way to
have him on is by just giving one of his
statements and then I want to see what
you Stefan have to say about it and then
same with yourself okay so Ed Whitton
was asked about whether the lack of
experimental data is the reason why
there's so many candidates for quantum
gravity and then he said I think your
premise is misleading string theory is
actually the only idea about quantum
gravity with any substance one sign is
that where critics of had interesting
ideas so non-commutative geometry black
hole entropy twister Theory they have
tended to be absorbed as a part of
string theory another sign is the way
that string theory has been successful
in generating new insights about
standard Quantum field Theory and even
about geometry okay so I'm curious to
know
Stefan what do you make of that what
would you say to Ed if he was here what
thoughts occurred to you and then same
with you Sarah yeah I think that um I
think that
as a person that that still publishes
and um you know and use I I publish
papers that use the framework of string
theory to to say
um you know to to speak to cosmology
speak to speak to
um
some issues of cloud particle physics
overlaps with cosmology in fact I'm
working on something right now that that
deals with electro-week unification
from the farm structures that come from
string theory and you know how they may
play out in theories like Cosmic
inflation so I can't speak too much
because I haven't put the paper out yet
and I'm still I'm still like fiddling
with with
um with with equations but so
I'm putting that out there to say that I
am a big fan of string theory and I do
think that it is from my opinion from
where I sit the most promising and
pragmatic because you know it does give
us a framework it gives us technology
um so that you know a person like myself
can actually formulate
um research problems in cosmology in my
case so I and or part of how particle
physics and cosmology speak to each
other
however I don't think that um you know
research at the um at the Forefront of
other approaches to quantum gravity
um takes away actually from um from you
know from String Theory I think that
it's important that we continue to
pursue
um research on all these fronts right so
I I know that there are some statements
that for example string theory is the
only game in town or string theory is
the only
um you know
formulation I mean we have things like
causal dynamical triangulation
um you know
um
covariant formulations non-preter
formulations of quantum gravity
um I was just visiting um a colleague um
Simon catarall at um Syracuse who
um does euclidean lattice quantum
gravity and their son to get very
interesting results that can get us back
to the set of space in some
semi-classical approximation that's you
know non-preservative they're again
open-ended issues there so again I think
that
um what's the word
the fact that string theory is in my
opinion the you know right now the most
developed framework with the most
workers in that field
um it doesn't take away from that fact
that there are other I think um viable
approaches uh of uh in in terms of
research and quantum gravity and and
they're certainly out there and they
have their problems but that's why as um
Leon Cooper said we knew what we were
talking about we wouldn't call it
research
euclidean lattice what
Quantum graphing
so this is very similar to what what um
you know Ken Wilson
um you know when you do
um lattice gauge Theory you formulate
um you use will you know you use um
Wilson Loops um and you work on a
lattice so you discretize space-time
and then you euclideanize and you work
on a computer and you you basically
solve the part partition function
non-preturbatively and then of course
you take a Continuum limit and you get
it and you show that you get back
um
um any Wick rotate back and you get back
you know qcd so the Hope says that you
can do the same thing for Gravity right
um right and so that's uh what those
guys work on are there non-preservative
approaches to string theory yes
so you know one um you know the two I
know about is Matrix
um Theory the so-called BFS matrix model
by Banks fischla Shanker and suskin and
then of course this is ikkt model
um of um
of that and I think also Lee smolen um
um had some turn Simon's Matrix Theory
um as well so and then of course ads CFT
is supposed to be a particular
non-perturbative definition of string
theory
um and you know in anti-decidis space
um so yeah yeah okay so you're just
giving you're reminding me of a
conversation from almost a year ago but
yeah going back to this whole thing that
you know that's that's my statement
about um you know
that um
right there's one thing for one Theory
to be more advanced and more developed
but that doesn't mean that you still
don't pursue research
um on other promising approaches and of
course it could be at the end of the day
that
um they you know that those
those
um what's the word that there's some
kind of um
thank you convergence yeah yeah so
that's my thought
what about you Sam
I'd like to pick up on that because uh
Professor Alexander actually brought up
a very interesting uh idea
why don't you say to the detractors of
ads equals CFT you know the whole idea
of anti-decider space equaling the
conformal field Theory the the whole
idea that we we live in a this sort of
vacuum hence the cosmological uh
constant must be positive because it's
been shown my data that the universe is
accelerating in its expansion hence
Lambda must be greater than one why
would you say to the detractors of ads
equals cfd that's my professor too
that's my question to you Professor
sorry yeah so I think adrcft is really
beautiful it's really beautiful stuff I
mean in a sense and it's deep I mean the
idea that wait a minute like you know
any theory of gravity and of quantum
gravity
um basically is is equivalent to or
encoded by with a theory with no gravity
and that theory looks very similar to
Yang Mills theory that yangmil's theory
right already contains any quantum
gravity yes that's a message there and
then of course there's this idea that
and that that that map is holographic
that you know that you know that that is
stored that information or that the
quantum gravity is in one dimension less
like a holographic screen I think it's a
really beautiful idea it's deep
um
ingenious um I think yeah so you know
tuft and suskin
um and of course what made Juan malasena
great we've also made one you know
amongst other things I mean he has done
some other amazing other things as well
in cosmology the um the buy Spectrum I
mean so he's you know
um so yeah so I'm just saying great
things because and and um and I'm so
however I do think that it is a um
it's a framework that we want we hope we
can carry over one day to
um to the set of space right or a um or
you know or minkowski space and people
are working on that you know actually my
colleague here at Brown um David Lowe is
one of the leaders in that field
um so people people on all this that's
an idea of course Celestial holography
right
um and I think that's a holographic
theories and such like you're looking
out in the sky and you're covered by a
two-dimensional surface that you know
that encompasses you and um that's so
it's a two-dimensional sub um holography
um so again these are I I know ideas
that people are actively working on but
ads CFT currently is just um
I don't it's not a I think it's it's
offensive to say that it's a toy model
but you know the idea is that we would
want to take some of that everything
that we've learned from ads CFT and put
it in a more realistic
um gravitational uh seven duel let me
let me uh enunciate why why I asked this
question because in that book there's a
great book in my opinion
um and I I'll give the professor's
correct name his name is Jacob Jacob
armas he goes by Jay because you know
for some reason as As Americans we fail
to pronounce correctly the names of
people I don't know why uh but anyway so
Jacon Professor shakoma Hamas he says uh
in his book uh conversations on quantum
gravity there's a a they own which by
the way I think in a second edition
Professor AMA should go to people like
you sir and to people like uh he uh
Professor Keating and Professor um and
and Dr Weinstein and uh yes uh why not
Sabino you know even though she you know
she she gets lost in math
and you know she she still has some some
bright ideas but again as long as you
don't put down other people's theories
and you don't say stupid things like
string theory is wrong and so forth I
think you can be dealt with uh you know
uh in a reasonable manner but um what
I'm saying is there should be a second
addition to this book where people such
as yourself and and other luminaries in
the field should be interviewed and you
know not just in Alaska by the way I
down the road if you have time I I want
to know your thoughts and as on
asymptotic safety as far as oh yeah yeah
Weinberg yeah I mean the may he rest in
peace since a great loss for for physics
anyway
um so so okay in in his com in the
conversation then Nima akani Hamed uh
he's kind of pushed against the wall
because Professor Hamas is basically
saying don't we live in the city
universe and so such and then Nema just
breaks down and says you know maybe ads
equals CFT is a gateway drug
to the emergence of space-time he
actually says this ad verbatim and I'm
like come on
okay what what what what what what do
you mean by that exactly a gateway drug
to the emergence of space-time the way
that I understand that is that Nema has
been saying for I don't know maybe two
decades now that space time is doomed
and there needs to be something that
that gives rise to space-time as an
emergent property and so he views that
as the most important program in physics
right now he has some approaches called
the amplitohedron maybe others he
doesn't care too much about whether ads
is unrealistic because it's anti rather
than not anti because he sees it as that
is one way that people can get into this
idea of an emergent space time and
that's where the real physics lies or
the real research lies yeah well I you
know I'm sympathetic to Nema and I think
if there's somebody that that will solve
that problem
and you know he went to school with
Sebastian no way yeah yeah they were
classmates no way no no way wow wow
that's amazing wow so two two two two
Geniuses in the same class huh
I tried to use that in my email to Nema
to come on to talk and but he doesn't
respond however I think we're making
some progress Nema will be on time yeah
yeah yeah Nema is awesome Nema is just
totally awesome I think Professor
Alexander one day you will solve one of
the great problems of this Earth I think
you will solve the vacuum catastrophe
can you speak more about your uh idea
you know the whole idea of the of the of
the um
why why the cosmological constant
between Quantum field Theory and general
relativity is is off by 120 orders of
magnitude is
like what that is I I think I think
I still think your Rhythm universe is is
absolutely brilliant would you talk more
about you know this idea of how how you
envision it's it's a
it's the way that you interpret
cosmology you have a very unique
understanding and I think people should
hear this so can you please announce it
you know what I'm talking about it's an
analogy but you know it's an analogy but
um it's based on this um it was yeah
yeah we tried to put some equations
behind it and then it ran into some
problems
um later on but I mean the first paper
did get you know it did get published in
a good Journal um because but then you
know but I think it yeah maybe you're
asking me to get me thinking I stopped
thinking about it for some time but the
basically please don't because I think
you have the right idea sir you have the
right idea keep on hammering don't let
these detractors you know just slow you
down please don't
that's all I gotta say I'm sorry to
interrupt go ahead
well the idea is that I mean you know so
why are the fundamental why are the
constants of nature what they are so
it's not just only the vacuum energy
it's the coupling you know it's a gauge
coupling constants it is that you call I
mean you know the when we look at the
yukawa you know the the mass matrices
like they you have different couplings
that the Higgs couples right
um so you have all these parameters in a
standard model so why are they what they
are so the theory that we have currently
do not explain that now one one
advantage of string theory one feature
string theory that is cool is that you
know coupling constants in in theories
in four dimensions right are really
Fields
um values of fields I've got expectation
values so then you can you can you can
turn the question on on us on strings
you and say why why do we have a vacuum
and string theory where the fields I did
get associated with the coupling
constants did get a vacuum expectation
value right you know so you can you can
sharpen that question in string theory
and in fact that's kind of one of the
things that we we said okay if we assume
that in a cosmology right we can we
allow actually for these
fields and then sometimes we call these
fields moduli right because they're
associated with the geometry of the
internal space so we have space time
four dimension we have these other Six
Dimensions that we can that can be
walked in ways that actually determine
um the coupling constants in the
four-dimensional world to vary so then
we can take this picture and package it
in the following way you can say well
imagine we what what what we what we
have is a cyclic universe so we and now
I'm now going to use so what actually
happens and that's what you say the
Rhythm the rhythmic universe so you have
a rhythmic a cycle where the universe
contracts bounces expands contracts and
it's been doing this you know for
eternity I love that idea right
absolutely yeah yeah so the idea here
can you hook that up to the quantum
bounce can you hook that up to the
hashtag car bounce because I think you'd
be right on you and Professor Ashoka
would win the Nobel I guarantee well we
have to make some predictions yeah how's
this different than other cyclical
models of the of cosmology it's
different in the sense of the following
what we were able to show is that if you
now couple
right you couple the the coupling
constants to the geometry what ends up
happening is that when you get close to
the bounce right the coupling constant
like a slot machine they they get
randomized
and then when you emerge out of the
bounds they freeze
so they got fixed interesting so at the
bounce is where all the randomization
happens and Brilliant the slot machine
gets gets gets shuffled or I call like
an improvisational universe that
basically you know in jazz music
um the rhythmic structure Cycles like a
blues 12 Bar blue it's it cycles and
every time you go around a cycle
somebody gets an opportunity to solo and
the solo or the improvisation is
basically the shuffling of the coupling
concept that was just the analogy it's
just an analogy
um that kind of clarifies the equations
so I see the idea is that the reason why
you gotta play your sacks you're gonna
yeah
I'm way out of practice I'm actually
getting prepared for a show next week
one quick question for Stefan then I
want to get to some questions for Sal so
Stefan the randomized coupling constants
do they have some different probability
distribution every time the universe
occurs like an evolution like lease
Mullen has an evolution model is it
actually the same randomization every
time yeah it's the same randomization
every time this talks to a paper an
archive I think May 27 2008 korichi and
sing
a Quantum bounce with Total Recall with
with Cosmic recall
they give the idea that the universe may
actually have total Cosmic recall oh
interesting right and it talks directly
to your Rhythm idea yeah I'll read those
papers because I I um I have a higher I
have a high I I know I know both I know
both of those guys and I have a high
opinion so I will definitely those
papers already yeah it's a great paper
yeah so what I want to know is what is
your Pious effect I want to hear what I
want to hear what Stefan's uh thoughts
are to it uh it's controlled motion of
electrically charged matter that varies
it could be electrically charged solids
to plasma so we're talking about four
state or matter here and you know the
idea of ions and electrons nice floating
around whatever now when you accelerate
these in in either spin or vibration you
get and especially if you use Rapid
acceleration transients uh so again this
whole idea of of the DDT of acceleration
but anyway
um you can get very high values of
electromagnetic energy flux and the
whole idea can be the for example you
can I believe under certain conditions
at least the classical Theory doesn't
give a limit but I believe under certain
condition you can have an exponential
run on on energies so you can get
schwinger limits we're talking about you
know things on the order electric fields
and the Order of of what 10 to the 18
volts per meter
commensurate with magnet with B fields
and the Order of 10 to the 9 Tesla now I
know that sounds crazy absolute crazy
but when you look at the at the theory
which comes right out of the Oliver
heavy side version of of of or Maxwell's
equations you you will know sir that
that Maxwell's equation is the original
ones first of all the way based on ether
vertical Theory and there were 20
equations with 20 unknowns almost
impractical from an engineering point of
view so Oliver and herbicide and The
Indian in the 1890s made possible these
you know four equations four unknowns
that we all use and love and in physics
courses in in undergrad he he made it
possible because otherwise if you were
to use the the correct quarter Iranian
formulism that Maxwell brought about oh
my goodness you know I'm not sure if
you'd get anywhere soon so so we all use
uh the four equation four unknown uh
natural equation that's really the
Oliver heavy side version of it so using
that I was able to bringing in you know
the harm the simple harmonic oscillator
uh mathematical formulasum I was able to
show that indeed it's possible to get
very high electromagnetic energy fluxes
by accelerating uh an electrical charge
basically either in spin or in vibration
because if you look at the mathematics
it's similar for both it's just that one
is the you know the the the the spin
radius times the angular frequency of
spin itself and the other for vibration
will be the amplitude of the vibration
times the angular frequency of vibration
you know so
from yeah but anyway uh that's what the
so-called pies effect is and a lot of
people have given me a lot of
consternation of over choosing the name
but I said look it's Original Number One
and number two uh uh uh I mean you know
I I could have called it the Feynman
effect but the man was far more
theoretical than he was experimental and
we actually tried to improve this
experimentally but we could never
achieve a an electrical charge higher
than 10 to the minus eight coulombs and
we really need a charge on the order of
one coulomb and
um uh Court which by the way has great
theoretical physics background I mean
this man that's why I agreed to be on
the top podcast and go with no one else
but Kurt because number one he has great
theoretical physics roots and great
mathematical knowledge he he had he
really understands this year my God
quantum gravity string theory he
understands it inside and out I mean who
else understands ads CFT quantum gravity
effects only come into play with high
energy Oh that's oh my God you know that
that's a subject of a paper
absolutely uh no I would say absolutely
not as a matter of fact condensed matter
physics can show you uh a direct
especially when it comes to this new the
topological Quantum matter but anyway uh
I I want to bring this up because uh
your
um your tall physics uh seminar or
I'm not sure exactly what to call when
you speak of natural units and you
actually give it's like almost two and a
half hours you you give uh um examples
of physical phenomena using natural
units uh you know the whole idea for
some Physics right the crash course and
physics the c equal H bar equal big J
whatever equal one uh um it is
absolutely phenomenal I I I think I must
have seen I think I watched that at
least six or seven times so so so if you
get like a lot of viewership from one
from One Source IP that that's your boy
right here oh yeah it's it's it's it's
what you like about it it's it's first
of all it's extra your your
um I mean it shows that you have the
correct pedigree and theoretical physics
your your knowledge of different
phenomena is a physical phenomena is
amazing up and not only that you're able
to make it an incredibly simple to
understand you know for for the Layman
for the but also for the theorem of
physicist you you bring um your new eye
a new uh again New Perspectives on all
physics I I just love that the phrase
but you really have that capability and
not only that but uh I mean you make me
want to come and talk podcasts over and
over whenever you want to have me I'm
I'm there as long as God forbid you know
somebody at the Navy doesn't realize
that I'm doing this and slaps me down oh
my God you don't want to know but anyway
so I'll just leave it there and um yeah
your your knowledge that's why because
in my opinion you are our theoretical
physicist doing podcasts choosing to do
that you know I mean you have the
ability for first of all you have the
ability to go in in in different
Sciences I for example your um is it
Carl friston I always get his name wrong
but I am absolutely I was um as well
with your knowledge of new of
neurophysiology the whole idea of the
free energy oh my God I was I was
incredibly impressed from that moment on
I knew that you could take out almost
any idea and I said if anybody would
understand the so-called bias effect or
this idea of the Super Force you would
and you know you you'd be able to say
something at least you know that's now
you're a crack party or Charlotte and
blah blah you know the crap that I
usually get so yeah you that's why I
keep on coming on this podcast that I'll
come on as long as you have me and my
so-called leaders don't tell me to cut
it out so yeah
a lot of people say how dare an engineer
enter the realm of theoretical physics
where only the gods reside you know but
sometimes sometimes
sometimes a human being May aspire
you know to to to to reach Mount Olympus
only to be you know struck down by the
gods but still
not trying would be worse
I agree with that thank you so much
that's all that's what the pious effect
is all about it's just uh uh
it it has promised the only problem is
nobody is willing to try it
experimentally sir because they all
think I'm a crackpot crank Charlotte
then whatever they would rather bring
about at home in them sorry about this
they would rather uh you know instead of
challenging my equation saying look
equation five and six in these in in his
paper and plasma blah blah is wrong fine
then we go back and we talk and say
under what assumptions could there you
see what I'm saying they're now willing
to engage me in in a in a discourse like
you are now which God bless you sir
thank you for doing this but uh uh
immediately at home and I'm a tax and
boom this affect this nonsense is
somebody called it I forget some
crackpot oh I'm sorry go ahead so to
reiterate quickly what is the pious
effect once more so that Stefan can
comment on it okay it's the controlled
motion of an electrically charged matter
in accelerated so either in accelerated
spin or accelerated vibration and the
going rapid acceleration transient so
again your acceleration is really a a
function of time
can can bring about high energy
electromagnetic fluxes so basically
energy transfer over surface area
so this thing can be used uh you know
either close to the electrical charge or
could be something that that somehow uh
the whole thing is that the
electromagnetic effects usually uh uh
they they decline as one divided by D
Square so away from the source like 10
meters away this thing is already one
divided by 100 weaker so but close to
close to the subject it could be very
high which which could talk to the
showing elements because what's the
showing element trying to do vacuum
decay of sorts well I wouldn't call it
vacuum that you got forbid we have a you
know the Mexican had potential and so
forth no no God forbid we live in a
false vacuum that I'd be the last to
know okay Stefan so you heard a
description of of what the pious effect
is so then what thoughts occurred to you
what are the unknowns
um well I mean so basically there's
something I mean definitely I mean
according to Maxwell's equations you can
have I mean by accelerated charges right
is there something like like that going
on there's like some collection
even spin or in vibration when you
accelerate them yeah so for example when
you pulse a current through a wire
you're really accelerating the electrons
through that one so
High electromagnetic energy fluxes could
could be you know could come into play
or when you electrically when you spin a
charge in an accelerated manner right
and you start actually changing the rate
of acceleration by for example
decelerating a little bit and then
accelerating at a higher Pace you can
they have very high energy fluxes it it
actually it makes sense really if if you
know Maxwell's equation no I mean if you
what you're saying you can set up a at
least at the very least I mean at the
level of a theory yeah a situation where
Maxwell's equation gives you high
electric flux
um from acceleration is that the idea I
mean
um I'm you know I you know Maxwell
equations um you know I mean and there's
that's that you need nothing Beyond
Maxwell equations to
to do this again it's coupled with the
idea of the harmonic oscillator because
that's how these okay because if if you
if you don't couple it with the idea of
um of Maxwell's um of the harmonica
why would you just create radiation I
mean normally when you accelerate things
I mean this one solution is that you the
electric and magnetic field couples each
other and then you get radiation all
right so how do you contain this flux
and and and instead of having it
radiated exactly
it's spherically it's radiating
everywhere but close to the object it's
a very high energy flux so you can get
these schwinger effects because if you
think of chewing the schwinners effect
is a Quantum effect though right yes
or is it something else
but see you you could say it's a
macroscopic Quantum phenomena if you
really think of the chewinger limit it's
really macro because he's speaking uh
even though he's thinking of the QED
vacuum uh breakdown
think what that means I mean really when
these electron positron page when this
The Rock C is being formed and you well
know that Iraq what that does what that
tells me that space time itself is being
torn apart I I I I have this feeling
that this is what this effect is
equivalent to it's like the space-time
fabric being torn apart
leads and the schwinger effect is
actually
would would do that because it will
bring to a breakdown I think the reason
Stefan's asking forgive like the correct
me if I'm incorrect is because he said
that the Maxwell equations are all
that's required for the pious effect and
and he was asking well what about
quantum mechanics or Quantum field
Theory and the swinger effect requires
that is that the reason why or no no no
uh what I'm saying what I'm trying to
say is that the harmonic oscillator
coupled with it with the uh the simple
Oliver heavy side version of Maxwell's
equation yields the so-called bias
effect but the bias effect is really a
macroscopic Quantum phenomena just like
for example remember how the London boys
the the London Brothers
created the London equations and came up
with the macros that superconductivity
was a macroscopic Quantum phenomena
what I'm saying this also happens on a
Quantum level
it's it's
not just classical yeah okay well we got
to get going soon so Stefan why don't
you just give your brief thoughts on
that and then I'll give an outro no I I
am listen this is um news to me and I'm
very interested in looking at those
looking at those equations
um you know because you know so go ahead
and send it along oh yeah yeah
absolutely sir you'll get everything I
got and this is a so-called is this is
this a patent of yours oh my God it's
got a lot of Pat I've been uh I've been
in the yeah it it got picked up by
certain papers and then it uh they
started calling it the UFO patents the
Navy UFO patents and you know from then
it just spiraled down into oh
you know and no no mainstream physicists
who taught you to the 10 foot because 10
football because it's associated
in my book you know in my and and I read
a book I recently I talked about you
know how we as human beings we always
you know we want to run away or don't
run away from stigma right
you give something a label like crack
talk or you what have you or you know or
in my case you know whatever you know
um people
try to keep away from that and it's you
know it's an unfortunate feature of
being a human being but it's
understandable and you know living and
you know being social creatures that we
are including those of us that like to
pretend that we're above that but you
know it's um it's um like you know
unfortunate that people want to you know
attach things like that you know look
Faraday when Faraday came up with this
idea of invisible lines of force I mean
you know maybe the word crockpot didn't
exist but I think word like idiot and
things like that happened it turned out
well in that case he turned out to be
correct that every you know feed the
field Paradigm is the Paradigm on the
line nature so
you know
that's just my my response about the
whole you know that people want to run
away from you know from from stigma in
that way yes sir thank you I want to
thank you both I also want to apologize
that I wasn't
and I'm not my best I'm just recovering
from like International illness covered
so my mind isn't I hope you feel better
sir get better soon I'll probably get
better soon speaking about Mass there's
so much mental inertia I have to
construct a sentence is extremely
difficult until remember where the
sentence began and where I'm going it
takes a terrible amount of effort I
appreciate you all dealing with me
through that okay and also for everyone
who is interested in Stefan's ideas and
sells ideas Sal you have a podcast on
theories of everything which I'll link
to and Stefan you also have a podcast on
theories of everything as well as two
books so Fear of a Black universe and
the Jazz of physics those will be linked
in the description and Stefan at some
point I would like to do a one-on-one
with you we'll talk about your
generalization of the Hawking hurdle
wave function and yeah you mentioned
that you're working on some Electro week
unification right now
yes I assume those are different yeah
the different might be related might it
might be related yeah so we can talk
about that and for the people who liked
when Stefan pulled out his computer and
wrote some equations we can have more of
that something that people's
surprisingly appreciate is the fact that
theories of everything can get technical
rather than just speaking in
generalities and Popular Science adages
so I look forward to speaking with you
again Stefan one-on-one as well and same
with you Sal when we have a one-on-one
maybe even in person
all right oh that'd be awesome oh my
goodness you know you know what would be
great if the three of us would get
together in person and just talk about
all I I bet you I know certain things
about decaf Avenue that you love to
remember sir I'm just saying you know
you forgot to play the saxophone oh yes
Stefan do you want to play saxophone as
a as oh come on is there something
quickly that's like a minute long come
on
let's see well that's like a poke yeah I
love this I don't know I don't know if I
don't know because um
I don't know how it works
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
mm-hmm
[Music]
friends
[Music]
[Music]
nice I have no idea what I was doing
there all right Bravo feel better please
get better thank you thank you so much
Sal thank you sir thank you for this oh
absolutely
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to
theoriesofeverything.org it's support
from the patrons and from the sponsors
that allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you